passer un certain âge les jeunes te
drague plus
j'ai pas vu un mandat
merci
bonsoir
et je lis mon courrier parce que comme
je n'habite pas à Paris je viens ici une
fois de temps en temps je suis affreuse
Amanda
les ans ne peuvent rien contre toi
merci c'est très gentil
dans cet endroit des souvenirs là
j'étais à 6 en train de prendre mon
chocolat
qui n'a pas changé depuis l'époque de
Dali j'évoquais justement ce que Dali
appelait les fruits déguisés c'est ces
petits machins là tous sucreries sablé
des fruits déguisés comprenez tous les
jours au thé avec d'un lit moi je
prenais mon chocolat enfin j'ai évoqué
tous ces souvenirs et je suis pour moi
c'est pétri de souvenirs ici alors on
fait du prout c'est ma madeleine ma
madeleine c'est l'hôtel Burns
j'ai rencontré Dali en 65 moi j'étais
mannequin donc je sais pas cours Rabanne
mais le cheveu bien raide le look
Françoise Hardy avec les dents et j'ai
rencontré dans dalliance 65 ici dans cet
hôtel
j'étais épaté impressionnée j'arrivais
de long j'avais ma mini-jupe pour des
fesses et tout et immédiatement d'aller
m'a dit venez déjeuner demain et le
lendemain je suis retrouvé à déjeuner
avec un trip de neuf avec des gens
j'étais tout épaté et depuis 65 donc on
sait plus quitté jusqu'à sa mort 89 donc
ça a duré 16 ans 17 ans
le grand compliment moi je m'étais quand
j'ai su que j'allais voir Dali
Paco Rabanne m'avait dit fais toi belle
ma chérie tout ça alors j'avais mis les
faux cils c'était bien qu'il y ait très
blanc j'étais belle comme tout on se
faisait la banane à l'époque et tout il
me regarde il me fait vous avez la plus
belle tête de mort que j'ai jamais vu
alors moi je me suis dit merde c'est
vrai je suis un peu maigre mais quand
même et alors là il m'a dit mais non
c'est un compliment et qu'est-ce qui se
passe alors
juste bien élevé mon daim un peu fou
est-ce que c'était réellement les deux
c'est à dire qu'il invitait tout le
monde au thé et il invite et les gens
sans discernement je veux dire toi chez
toi tu mélangerais pas faut pas le
président TF1 avec ta copine de des
Bains Douches
mais lui il invitait tout le monde alors
tu rencontrais Gainsbourg a aussi bien
avec l'ambassadeur d'Espagne avec un
Rothschild avec un vieux hippique il
avait trouvé chez Castel tous un
mélangeait donc dans le salon là haut
tout simplement déjà arrivé tous mes
amis ce que la moi uniquement pour la
voir un peu de succès parce qu'on dit
c'est si on est avec Dali peut-être je
risque de sortir dans une photo
sont des arrivistes parce que en sachant
quand un amour voire leur truc leur
photographie leur disque
se vendront un peu ce qui est pas vrai
parce que la plupart des gens qui
m'approchent après
il leur arrive ce que il est arrivé à
Jul brahimie qui n'a pas de cheveux a
beaucoup d'autres ils viennent
m'approcher après ils perdent en
américain s'appelle perdre leurs jambes
c'était ils viennent avec l'illusion de
phénomène grande succès après on leur
faut à la porte de là où ils sont
employés mais pour le moment très
souvent après m'avoir connu quelques
temps tous une perle leur situation de
là où il se trouve entrer du champagne
volontiers très glacée très pétillant
merci
[Musique]
tout ce petit monde buvait du don
Perignon ce qui rend des gars là parce
qu'elle disait tu dépenses des fortunes
pour ces cons parce que la pluie
c'est difficile pour un mec de dire
voilà maintenant de dire à sa femme je
te présente ma maîtresse
tu as déjà vu ses mains comment elles
sont longues alors regarde la disait oui
oui j'ai vu elle est belle mais en fait
ça va il y en a rajouté et petit à petit
il m'a fallu un petit à petit plusieurs
mois pour que gala m'accepte et pour que
Gallame invite et une fois que gala a
dit bon on invite à mandat en Espagne
chez eux bon les gars alors là c'était
un grand pas de franchi parce que là-bas
en plein soleil on était plus dans les
dorures
on était en Espagne c'était leur maison
à eux dans leur intimité et là elle
était plus sympa alors là elle mâle m'a
reçu vraiment comme je pense ça aurait
pu mettre ma grand-mère tu vois et elle
me disait écoutez je suis allé jaloux
c'est vrai
je veux que mon mari soit heureux si mon
mari est heureux avec Amanda tant mieux
si il est malheureux sans Amanda ça va
être malheureuse donc je veux alors ça
je trouve ça extraordinaire parce que
moi je suis hyper jaloux je n'envisage
rien
moderne t'aurais pas accepté mais ce qui
s'est passé des choses entre vous trois
n'ont jamais
et toi tous les trois
tu sais que gala avait 10 ans plus que
Dali c'était une femme déjà dans dans
très Cérébra elle tenait son petit
journal en russe elle adorait les
écrivains c'était autre chose qu'elle
arrêtait tellement sur la chose
si regardez les choses de dire des
filles de ses habiller alors les filles
évidemment elle s'est habillées parce
qu'elles se disait c'est un grand
peintre c'est génial on pouvait pas dire
non analyse il disait déshabillez-vous
je voudrais voir la courbe de votre
hanche etc tout le monde à poil et après
il est dessiné pas du tout ou alors il
faisait semblant mais il aimait bien un
petit peu se rincer l'oeiler à être dans
les et je m'y approche mais c'est très
compliqué parce que c'est une lettre
tellement sublime que je sais pas si je
vais y atteindre et dis-moi sexuellement
comment ça va alors
ça va très bien merci je pense que
arrivé un certain âge on a plus de
succès je croyais que c'était le
contraire je m'imaginais pas ces 35 ans
haïr ça va être la pauvre fripée les
gamins ne vont plus me regarder et ben
c'est le contraire passer un certain âge
les jeunes te draguent plus et
curieusement on se sent beaucoup mieux
dans sa peau parce qu'on est une femme
d'expérience on sait ce qu'on aime on
sait ce qu'on aime pas et ça se passe
beaucoup mieux c'est curieux
j'ai suffisamment d'aventures pour
garder le moral
est-ce qu'on vit sans tu fais des trucs
de plus en plus compliqués ou est-ce que
finalement tu as toujours des relations
sexuelles relativement traditionnelles
c'est à dire que j'ai des périodes de
grande libido déchaînés à la Libération
assez assez déchaîné et puis après c'est
suivi d'une période de contraint de
grands repentir
la limite du mysticisme ou alors là ne
me parlait surtout pas de sexe est une
horreur je sublime tout dans mon art
j'ai lu un truc très drôle de toi c'est
étudier maintenant il y a plus de
batterie qui me dit que je suis un homme
c'est emmerdant quand même parce que ça
faisait partie de ta légende
non je pense que
petit à petit les gens ne le disent plus
ou n'osent plus le dire et c'est très
curieux parce que moi j'avais toujours
pensé que jusqu'à ce que j'ai 90 ans
meurt traversant la rue je me suis dit
les gens ils n'oublieront jamais ça ils
oublieront le titre de mes chansons dieu
merci d'ailleurs ils ont environ
[Rires]
oui le look ils oublieront mes émissions
télé dieu merci aussi mais on dira mais
qui c'était déjà un nom de vous savez
bien on sait que c'était un homme ah
celle-là tu vois je me suis dit ça il
oubliait parce que dès que tu touches un
petit peu l'identité sexuelle c'est et
puis je vois quand on vieillissant je me
suis un peu en bourgeoise et on me voit
comme ça et donc tout ça on dit non mais
il y a aussi il faut penser que on parle
d'une époque où c'était avant prince
avant Michael Jackson avant RuPaul avant
tout ça donc
tout ce qui était un petit peu
bisexuel ambiguïté ça faisait jaser
maintenant on s'en fout tu vois le
Michael Jackson tu vois tout le monde tu
t'en fous pratiquement de leur vie
sexuelle donc c'est vrai qu'on a on a
fait on a peut-être été tellement sa
banalisé mais moi j'ai encore vu
quelqu'un cet après-midi qui m'a juré
que tu étais un homme non mais
sérieusement pourquoi dire qui me dit
mais vraiment qui me dit mais je connais
très bien son cousin il est à
Montpellier Amanda s'appelle Alain non
mais sérieux non mais très très
sérieusement il m'a juré quoi
à Montpellier il dit qu'il est ton
cousin que tu t'appelles tu sais c'était
attends de Montpellier c'est peut-être
comme le concert de Mitterrand parce que
Mitterrand finalement il disait toujours
j'ai pas le cancer j'ai pas le cancer il
l'avait peut-être qu'un jour quand tu
seras morte il y a ton toubib qui dira
tu vois Grüber locale qui dira attendez
mais moi d'ailleurs maintenant je peux
vous le dire c'est moi qui l'ai opéré
attends
tu te feras incinérer pour qu'on puisse
pas faire de Topsy voilà on lui donne
encore à la science ou de me retrouver
en beau mais qu'on vienne me visiter au
musée tu
une de mes une de mes citations
préférées c'est une citation de Louis II
de Bavière que j'aime beaucoup que Dali
mais beaucoup d'ailleurs Louis de ma vie
il a dit sur sa tombe je crois que
c'était écrit je veux rester une énigme
pour moi-même et pour tout le monde mais
pour moi-même aussi mais dis-moi
pourquoi tu as jamais fait d'enfant
parce que ça aurait été une façon
définitive de prouver que tu t'imagines
en fait d'abord faire un enfant
maintenant tout le monde sait que c'est
une vraie femme quoi c'est pas des
enfants juste pour montrer qu'on a des
ovaires heureusement moi j'ai trop qu'on
fait des enfants parce qu'on a un foyer
à leur donner alors moi les actrices ou
les chanteurs qui font des enfants après
c'est dur ouais qu'il est trimballe dans
la loge dans un panier et qui vont ah
non non extraordinaire c'est le nombre
de stars qui font des enfants et trois
mois après tu lis dans Voici
j'avais travaillé quand on est la Mouti
en Italie elle venait d'avoir un homme
donc et elle travaillait dans un panier
dans la loge avec la fumée les
paparazzis les photographes le
maquillage je sais mais enfin c'est
enfant n'a pas sa place ici
et puis si on fait un enfant bon alors
tu t'arrêtes comme ça
en vrai alors devant tout le monde elle
sortait c'est pas ma confiance lui donne
un foyer on n'est pas dans les journaux
on fait pas des photos à poil on n'est
pas la télé on est une mère de famille
tu pars comment là tu pars en taxi je
pars en voiture dieu merci et je cours à
Orly toi même ta voiture
vous connaissez pour pas fumer
alors c'est une nouveauté pour pas fumer
ça sent la vieille chaussette je le fais
pas en effet ça sent une horreur c'est
un truc que tu renives ça sent vraiment
la vieille chaussette dégueulasse et ça
t'empêche de film parce que c'est à base
d'airbes ce sont des herbes moi j'ai un
truc à base d'herbe qui évite de fumer
des
reconnais et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu